Welcome to the intermediate control rig course in Unreal Engine version 5.5.
We're going to be following on from the introduction to control rig course,
where we'll be continuing to build the rig that we created in that class.
This time we'll look at some new tools and techniques that will help simplify and improve the control rig,
as well as some new functions and control types to develop your overall control rig knowledge.
We'll be continuing to build our rig from the introductory class,
building in a more modular series of exercises this time that you can then learn from and use to build into your own rig.
We'll take a look at a new function called the IK2Bone function,
improving on the basic IK node that we were using last time and simplifying our setup,
as well as how to create and utilize your own custom functions in your own function library.
And then we'll take a look at two other control types, nulls and floats,
to see how you can gain an extra level of control within your rig.